hey I'm dr. Mike Marsh ostia
board-certified family medicine
physician and I want to take on the top
10 questions on Cova 19 that I received
from my friends family social media and
even my patients can pets transmit covet
19 Danza to that question is both yes
and no no because pets don't seem to be
having symptoms of kovat 19 they're not
coughing they're not having fevers so
we're saying that they don't seem to be
infected with it that being said if you
go for a walk and you have a very cute
puppy-like bear and someone wants to pet
it and they just sneeze into their hands
and they touch your dog and now your dog
comes home you touch your dog you can
bring that virus and introduce it into
your own body so yes
pets can be carriers of this virus as a
surface so you're gonna be socially
distancing yourself also get your pets
to specially distance themselves too
should I use soap to wash my produce
well I've actually gotten this question
a lot recently because of a viral video
of a doctor doing just that and the
truth of the matter is not only do not
need to do this you shouldn't most
fruits and vegetables are porous meaning
they can absorb the soap and that's not
great for your stomach it can cause all
sorts of gastrointestinal symptoms like
nausea vomiting diarrhea all you have to
do to disinfect your fruits and
vegetables is to run them under cold
water that's gonna get 90 to 95 percent
of whatever is out there off of them is
it okay if I throw a mini party but we
all stay six feet apart the answer to
this question is a hard no social
distancing means physical distancing and
more than six feet apart the reason why
we give the 6 foot guidance is in case
you have to go out to do your grocery
shopping or your an essential employee
like a doctor or nurse then yes 6 feet
makes sense to mitigate the risk it's
not a hundred percent foolproof imagine
one of your friends comes over they're
asymptomatic meaning they're having no
symptoms but they have Kovan 19 now they
give it to you you give it to one of
your family members in your home and
they have serious consequences not
something you want should I be taking an
immune boosting supplement I get really
mad when I see claims made by marketing
companies say that they have an immune
boosting shake or detox drink or
supplement they don't exist there's no
such thing as boosting your immune
system your immune system works because
you have vitamins minerals inside your
body that you get natural
from foods or they're created within
your own body you do not need more of
them the analogy I like to give folks is
like a construction site if you want the
construction to be done sooner you can't
just deliver more materials and think
that's gonna speed up the process in
fact I can create more problems so no
taking a huge amount of vitamin D and C
and E and zinc is not gonna help you
protect yourself from covet 19 it's just
never been proven well if not
supplements how can i boost my immune
system well the answer is again you're
not trying to boost your immune system
you're trying to optimize it in fact a
boosted immune system almost makes it
sound like you have an autoimmune
disorder where your own immune system is
attacking your body you don't want that
to optimize your immune system you
should focus on the four pillars of
health sleep getting at least seven to
nine hours a night studies have shown
that if you get less than six hours it
drops your natural killer cells by up to
50% and they're responsible from
protecting you from kovat 19 to eat
healthy get fruits get vegetables make
sure you're loading up on the good stuff
3 exercise now is no better time than
ever to exercise do some sit-ups take a
class on your TV on your iPad iPhone or
go out for a run like I do I've fallen
in love with running because of Nike and
for don't engage in bad habits smoking
can increase your chance of having a
severe case of kovat 19 2 to 3 times
over drinking impairs your monocytes the
type of white blood cell that protects
you from kovat 19 is kovat 19 an
airborne virus the preliminary research
says no it looks like the main form of
transmission for this virus is through
respiratory droplets that's what happens
when you sneeze or cough and you see
that fine mist shoot out into the air
now those germ particles tend to be
heavier so they don't spend a lot of
time in the air they end up falling to
the ground now these germs do have some
hang time and I've seen media already
make a huge spectacle that this virus
can live in the air for up to three
hours while yes we've seen small
particles actually genetic material of
this virus live in the air for a period
of up to three hours we have no evidence
that those particles can actually get
people sick so for now the main forms of
spread we need to be concerned about is
respiratory droplets and contact so you
really have to avoid touching your mouth
nose or eyes because that's how the
virus enters your system
as an exception for medical facilities
when we're doing specific procedures
like an intubation or we have a patient
of a specific type of breathing machine
called BiPAP we have seen some particles
of this virus aerosolize that's why in a
medical setting we have really quality
protection like n95 masks or papper
systems so the medical professionals
don't get sick around them what can I do
to lower my anxiety and depressive
symptoms during quarantine the first
issue that arises during the quarantine
is a lack of social connections we as
humans are social beings we need that
type of interaction remember we're all
in the same boat here
there's no FOMO to be had so reach out
and schedule a date on FaceTime do a
Skype with their entire family so you
could stir up a little trauma
just keep that interaction in your life
it's really important second limit your
time on the internet and checking the
news my god all the numbers being thrown
at you the outbreak warnings this is
really anxiety provoking so check it
once a day or maybe even every other day
and three pick up a new hobby painting
reading exercising anything because as
someone wise once said an idle mind is a
devil's playground is it true that
taking ibuprofen or Advil / motrin can
make Cova 19 symptoms worse this started
when the French minister came out and
made a warning about this there has been
zero evidence that shows ibuprofen
directly makes Kovan 19 symptoms worse
the w-h-o even came out and made a
statement about this saying that they
did not advise discontinuing ibuprofen
in kovat 19 patients that being said
we're still doing more research and
we're still figuring out how I can play
a role in kovat 19 symptoms but the
answer is easy if you don't have to take
ibuprofen and you have an other option
like I said a meta fen aka Tylenol do it
an easier mind should the general public
be wearing masks to decrease spread of
kovat 19 there are two types of masks
that are being discussed in this
conversation first are n95 masks these
are the professional form-fitting masks
you see doctors and nurses wear on the
frontlines to protect themselves these
masks keep the virus out then you have
the loose-fitting inexpensive surgical
masks that actually prevent you from
putting the virus out so basically this
is meant for sick people but patient
comes into my office they're coughing
all over the place we pull one of the
masks on now with kovat 19 having so
many asymptomatic sick patients meaning
that we don't even know they're sick
perhaps there's some logic and having
everyone wear these masks
well the w-h-o has never recommended for
the general healthy public to wear these
surgical masks first there's a huge
shortage of these masks right now for us
as health professionals - it gives you a
false sense of security to feel like oh
maybe I can go out because I'll just
wear this inexpensive mask remember it
doesn't protect you it protects everyone
else and then three there's really
limited scientific research saying that
it truly helps flatten the curve is
ordering food delivery safe nothing is a
hundred percent safe but if you're going
to be ordering food delivery do it the
best way you can and take some
precautions make sure that when you
order on the app you click the no
contact delivery option most of the big
apps post mate's caviar they all have
them next when you get the items make
sure that when you bring them in your
home you wash your hands first then you
unpack the items you wash your hands
again you eat and you touch some of the
containers afterwards wash your hands
again it's really about washing your
hands washing your hands washing your
hands and just know if someone who had
Cova 19 handled your food it's a very
low likelihood that you will actually
get the virus transmitted to you through
that way I highly recommend you check
out my interview that I did with dr.
Anthony pouchy here or if you want to
see some serious misinformation get
corrected from politicians and media
click here for that playlist and as
always gotta stay happy and healthy
[Music]